the White House and Congress are working
on measures to limit the economic damage
from the pandemic we Shashank is at the
White House we show what is being
considered at this point well Anthony
there are a lot of options on the table
as president Trump warns this outbreak
is bad for weeks he had been urging
Americans to relax and stay calm but
yesterday his tone was markedly more
somber in addition to avoiding social
gatherings with more than 10 people he
did not rule out taking more drastic
actions like ordering regional
quarantines and on a call with the
nation's governors mr. Trump told them
to find critical supplies of respirators
and masks on their own because federal
help may be too slow this week the
Senate is expected to pass a stimulus
bill that already cleared the house to
provide paid sick leave as well as free
virus testing and today on Capitol Hill
secretary Treasury of the Treasury
Stephen minuchin is expected to talk
about a third spending package a
stimulus bill that would actually be
aimed at helping small businesses as
well as the hotel and airline industries
deal.we Joe we were hearing yesterday
that many lawmakers are floating the
idea of monthly cash payments to help
Americans get through this crisis you
know Andrew yang talked a lot about
giving people money during his campaign
what can you tell us about that well
Senator Tom cotton who we know is a
close ally of President Trump as well as
Senator Mitt Romney have both proposed
some version of this cotton wants to
provide stipends to low and middle class
families to buy food and pay bills and
Romney's proposal would send $1,000 to
every American adult to help them meet
short-term obligations and help boost
the economy something like this could
have a huge price tag but the fact that
you have the moderate Romney the more
conservative a cotton and several
Democrats pushing this idea means it
could get some serious consideration
Gale all right we shall thank you very
much